[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild ich mein dre Versprechen gegeben
und das ist mein letztes was ich noch
einlösen muss ihr habt gerade die
Thüringerin syvia wiwer gehört eine
große schlanke Frau in ihren 50ern ihre
glatten blonden fallen ihr ins Gesicht
ihre strahlenden blauen Augen zeigen
Entschlossenheit die Frau hat schon früh
einen schweren Verlust durchleben müssen
denn ihre geliebte Schwester Carmen
kleem wird vor über 30 Jahren grausam
vergewaltigt und ermordet eine lange
Zeit ist seitdem vergangen doch auch die
Staatsanwaltschaft Erfurt hofft immer
noch auf einen Durchbruch Mord verhehrt
nicht das heißt eine Straftat wegen Mord
nach Paragraph 211 Strafgesetzbuch kann
immer aufgeklärt werden solange der
Beschuldigte noch lebt wem fällt die
junge Karmen damals zum Opfer wer ist
seit Jahrzehnten der Hauptverdächtige
der aber nie gefasst worden ist wie lebt
eine Schwester über die Hälfte ihres
Lebens lang mit einem solchen Verlust
mein Name ist Sky Dumont und ich begrüße
euch zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Tatort
Deutschland einem Cold Case einem bisher
unaufgeklärten Mordfall was geschah mit
Carmen
KEM Deutschland im Juli
1989 es ist der letzte Sommer der DDR
die Leute sind aufgebracht fliehen über
Ungarn aus dem Osten nach
Westdeutschland Proteste auf den Straßen
der Wille nach Freiheit brodelt so
explosiv in der Luft wie nie zuvor kurz
vor dem Fall der Mauer ereignet sich ein
schockierender Mordfall die gerade
einmal 22-Jährige Krankenschwester
Carmen kleem wird am 6 juli tot im
thüringischen Sömmerda aufgefunden nur
wenige 100t Meter von ihrem Elternhaus
entfernt auch die Bildzeitung berichtet
damals regelmäßig über den Mord im
Sommer 89 wurde unsere Schwester
ermordet wer kennt den Killer meiner
Schwester warum konnte Carens Killer
noch nicht gefunden werden eine junge
blonde Frau mit einem damals wie auch
heute wieder modischen Pony über den
wachen Augen sie ist ein glückliches
Mädchen am Anfang ihres Erwachsenen
Lebens und hat noch viel vor bei der
Arbeit im Krankenhaus blüht sie auf sie
will sogar studieren und selbstärztin
werden doch das Schicksal hat andere
Pläne für Sie denn ihr wird nach einer
unbedeutenden Diskonacht das Leben
genommen Bildreporter Carsten K ist
zuständig für die Bild in Thüringen und
verfolgt die Ermittlungen seit Jahren
das aufgeschlagene Notizbuch ist voller
alter Notizen zu dem Mordfall der
Journalist stüzt das kin mit dem weißen
Dreitagebart auf die geballte Faust in
all den Jahren versuchten die Ermittler
immer wieder ihr Bestes doch erfolglos
mich fasziniert besonders an dieser
Geschichte die Schwester von Carmen
kleen sie hat ein letztes versprechen
ihren Eltern gegeben ich werde den Täter
finden kamen Schwester Silva Witwer BBT
noch immer in sömmer da und kümmert sich
aufopfernd um das Grab ihrer Schwester
Carmen und ihrer mittlerweile ebenfalls
verstorbenen Eltern der Friedhof ist
fußläufig von syvias zu Hause entfernt
hierhin hat sie kamen extra umbetten
lassen Bildreporter K trifft Silvia die
frische Lilien für ihre Schwester
gekauft hat und neben ihrem lächelnden
Foto auf dem Grabstein platziert was
bedeutet das das Grab ihrer Schwester
jetzt unmittelbar neben ihren Wohnhaus
zu haben ja ich habe ich habe keinen
Zeitdruck mehr also ich kann zu jeder
Tag und
Nachtzeit hierhergehen und
kann Blumen hinstellen und mich um die
Grabpflege kümmern denn das ist mir sehr
wichtig dass es immer im ordentlich
aussieht ich re hier mein segrätchen
trink mein Radler wenn ich feieramend
habe und unterhalte mich halt mit den
Dreien was man so am Tag über erlebt hat
gute Sachen schlechte Sachen worüber man
sich geärgert hat dass man ein Zuhörer
und haben sie dann auch das Gefühl sie
sei noch da sie hört ihm zu die sind
immer da
aber wenn sie nur liegen aber s sind
halt immer da kamen und syvia Tränen nur
10 Monate deshalb wachsen sie quasi wie
Zwillinge auf syvia schenkt dem Reporter
ein Lächeln während sie von ihrer
Schwester erzählt doch ihre Trauer lässt
sich kaum verbergen komm ruhiger ruhig
zurückhaltend aber irgendwie doch immer
im Mittelpunkt also sie war eben ein
besonderer Mensch nicht jetzt weil das
passiert ist sondern die haben die ist
von jeden gemacht worden die hatte
wunderschöne Augen da hat alles gestimmt
ich habe mir immer ein Beispiel an ihr
genommen aber ich bin nie rangekommen an
sie silver will nach über drei
Jahrzehnten unendlich Gerechtigkeit um
mehr über die rechtliche Lage zu
erfahren stattet Reporter keh dem
Oberstaatsanwalt Hannes grünseisen einen
Besuch ab dieser führt den Journalisten
in sein verglastes Büro in ehfurt von
dem aus man fast schon einen
Panoramaausblick über die
Landeshauptstadt hat anhand eines
straßennetzplans der Kreis sömmer da
erklärt grünseisen wo das Verbrechen in
der besagten Nacht stattgefunden hat
Herr grünseisen was können Sie uns
erzählen über diese Nacht vom 1 zum 2
juli
1989 in der Carmen kleen ihren letzten
Weg genommen hat wo ging der genau lang
Geschädigte befand sich in der Nacht in
der mitternachtsdisco im im
jugendclubhaus in sömmer da seiner Zeit
hat dort getanzt und hat gegen 1:30 Uhr
mit einer Freundin die Diskothek dann
verlassen und ging dann hier entlang
zusammen mit der Freundin dort bei der
Bahnhofstraße trennten sich die beiden
jungen Frauen zurück im Jahr
1989 ganze 2,5 km trennen die Wohnung
von Carens Freundin von ihrem Elternhaus
Oberstaatsanwalt grünseisen fährt mit
dem Finger auf der Karte entlang Carmen
geht diesen langen Weg mitten in der
Nacht ganz allein und trifft dort
irgendwo auf ihren
die genauen Details will die Polizei
nicht preisgeben fakt ist jedoch vor
ihrer Ermordung wird Carmen
vergewaltigt Carsten K läuft mit
Schwester Silvia die Straßen ihres
ehemaligen Wohnviertels in sömerda ab
eine ruhige Gegend in der überwiegend
Familien wohnen an der Stelle vor ihrem
damaligen Elternhaus bleiben sie stehen
hier steht mittlerweile ein Wohnblock
Silvia erinnert sich genau an den Tag
der Tat der Bildreporter versucht mit
ihr zu rekapitulieren wie die Familie
überhaupt von dem Vorfall erfahren hat
hier stand früher ihr elternhus als die
dann aus ihrem Urlaub zurückkamen und
kammen war nicht da wie haben Sie sich
denn da verhalten erstmal war das für
sie nicht schlimm weil sie ja öfters
genächtigt hat bei ihrem Freund aber als
dann
[Musik]
die Meldung vom Krankenhaus kam dass sie
nicht auf Arbeit erschienen ist was für
kam sehr untypisch war auf kam war immer
Verlass dann sind sie hellhörig geworden
und da haben sie vermissen ein zeigebar
der Polizei gest kamen ist zu diesem
Zeitpunkt jedoch bereits tot erst vier
Tage später wird ihre Leiche von einem
Anwohner in einem Gebüsch gefunden und
das in unmittelbarer Nähe von Carens
damaligen zuuh Hause tagelang liegt das
Mädchen dort Hitze Regen und ungeziefern
ausgesetzt dementsprechend ist ist sie
kaum wieder zu erkennen ein
fürchterlicher
Anblick Werbung Susi ich glaube ich hab
es endlich ein Podcast den wir beide
zusammen hören können pass auf es geht
um Sport und Verbrechen also True Crime
jetzt hast du mich True Crime das
gefällt mir richtig gut erzähl mir mehr
das habe ich mir gedacht playing dirty
Sport und Verbrechen heißt der Podcast
es geht um Sportstars Trainer oder
Manager die irgendwie mit dem Gesetz in
Konflikt geraten sind okay das ist
hochaktuell da fallen mir gleich zwei
ein Jerome Boateng und unser Boris
Becker um die beiden geht's auch aber
die Liste ist echt lang ne allein in
Deutschland Ulli höhnes Christoph Daum
Jan Ulrich aber auch international gibt
so krasse Fälle ne Oscar Pistorius oder
OJ Simpson auf jeden Fall und ich frag
mich da halt immer wie sind die in den
Strudel von Lügen Intrigen und Gewalt
geraten und quasi wann haben Sie die
falsche Abzweigung genommen und
überhaupt wieso also das interessiert
mich total und genau diese Fragen die
klären die beiden Hosts Lena Kassel und
Daniel müch in playing dirty Lena Kassel
ist Moderatorin Journalistin und
podcasterin z.B auch beim Podcast
Fußball MML einer der erfolgreichsten
sportpodcasts in Deutschland daniel müch
ist renomierter Sportjournalist hat
schon großen Podcast über Boris Becker
gemacht unser Boris und jetzt haben sie
zusammen den Podcast playing dirty und
jeden Donnerstag gibt es eine neue Folge
im Podcast Player eures
Vertrauens Werbung
Ende Carens Schwester syvia kämpft mit
den Tränen während sie sich an den
bisher wohl schlimmsten Tag ihres Lebens
zurückerinnert ich habe nur die Jacke VK
gesehen die hat den Polizist über den
Arm gelegt und das war eine Jacke die
auch unsere Tante genäht hat die wir
auch gleich hatten so ein Bolero jägchen
aber sie selbst haben sie damals zu dem
Zeitpunkt nicht gesehen wir durften sie
nicht sehen weil
das äußere Erscheinungsbild von kam so
schlimm war dass wir Sie nicht uns
angucken sollten es war ja sehr heiß es
war
Regen und da kann man sich Bild machen
wie es ausgesehen hat vier Tage hat sie
ja bei der wetterung draußen gelben das
war wie
und Stich ins
Herz als diese Todesnachricht kam von
ihrer
Schwester wie ging es für ihre Eltern
weiter ja meine Mutter ist über Nacht
weiß geworden die HA die HA die war
übern übernchtt die war die waren anders
da war alles nicht mehr so wie es war
vorher 120 Ermittler sind kurz nach dem
Leichenfund an dem Fall dran zunächst
geht man davon aus dass sich bei dem
Täter um einen der vielen
Schichtarbeiter nahgelegener Betriebe
handelt die auch nachts unterwegs sind
doch plötzlich zieht auch einer von
Carens damaligen Nachbarn die
Aufmerksamkeit auf sich Bildreporter
Karsten K will von Oberstaatsanwalt
Hannes grünseisen wissen wie es dazu
gekommen ist wie sind ihm die Ermittler
damals auf die Spur gekommen das ist
richtig es gab seiner Zeit einen
Beschuldigten der hatte sich nach
Auffinden der Leiche verdächtig
verhalten hatte dort gegenüber
eingesetzten
Volkspolizisten Täterwissen offenbart
also wissen offenbart was man eigentlich
nicht haben kann wenn man an der Tat
nicht beteiligt war er wurde daraufhin
auch vorläufig festgenommen er befand
sich 5 Monate seiner Zeit in
Untersuchungshaft der Verdächtige holg s
wohnt damals genau gegenüber von Carmens
Elternhaus er macht sich negativ
bemerkbar als er die junge kamen beim
Sonnen mit einem Fernglas beobachtet
auch die Schwester Silvia Witwer
erinnert sich an die Anschuldigungen
gegenüber holg s da haben wir ein Bild
vorgezeigt gekriegt
und ich war diejenige die
ihn erkannt hat aufgrund dessen weil er
mit zu uns zur Schulspeisung gegangen
ist ja und daher kannte ich ihn und als
ich das Bild gesehen habe dann
kam eine Lehrer so eine Lehrer im Kopf
so ein Absinken so ein ein ganz Komis
Gefühl als wie also die innere Eingebung
hat sofort gesagt ja das könnte der sein
ein Nachbar der die junge kamen schon
kennt ein Mann zu dem sie vielleicht
auch ein gewisses Vertrauen hat hegt
holg es insgeheim Gefühle fürkamen oder
ist es gar eine krankhafte Besessenheit
steht er mit der Vergewaltigung seine
Begierde und bringt das Mädchen
schließlich aus Verzweiflung um
schließlich kennt die junge Frau ihn
trotz des Verdachts wurde hol S bis
heute nicht als Täter überführt
Oberstaatsanwalt Hannes grünseisen
erklärt weshalb es gab 32 Vernehmungen
fast 270 Stunden ist er vernommen worden
in keiner einzigen dieser Vernehmung hat
er irgendeine Tatbeteiligung eingeräumt
oder konnten irgendwelche objektiven
Beweise dann dingfest gemacht werden so
dass am Ende das Verfahren eingestellt
wurde weil kein hinreichender
Tatverdacht
Bestand der Fall sich im Jahr
1989 die Mittel und Wege der
wissenschaftlichen Untersuchungen
verbessern sich bis heute stetig
fortschrittliche Methoden die ein klein
wenig Hoffnung geben es sind ja auch
Spermaspuren gefunden worden aber auch
mit den jetzigen Untersuchungsmethoden
konnten diese nicht soweit
individualisiert werden dass man sie
einer konkreten Person zuordnen könnte
aber die Wissenschaft verbessert sich ja
ständig und man darf in so einem Fall
die Hoffnung nie aufgeben dass der Fall
dennoch auch anhand der jetzt noch
vorhandenen spurenextrakte gelöst werden
könnte doch es bleibt die Frage wer hat
der erst 22-Jährigen auf so schreckliche
Weise das Leben genommen war es Holger s
am Ende doch nicht auch Carsten K kann
nur Vermutungen anstellen wir wissen
nicht was sich damals genau hier
abgespielt hat hat sie z.B einen
Liebhaber zurückgewiesen oder gibt es
einen ganz anderen Verdächtigen den die
Polizei noch gar nicht auf dem Schirm
hat allen Hinweisen wurde nachgegangen
alle Ermittlungen eingestellt der Mord
von Carmen kleemen wird zu einem Cold
Case für Carmens Schwester silvia ist
der Kampf um Gerechtigkeit jedoch noch
lange nicht vorbei sie hat jahrelang
gespart und eine Belohnung von 10 000 €
für jeden zum täterführenden Hinweis
ausgesetzt obwohl sie als Obst und
Gemüseverkäuferin nicht viel Geld
verdient würde Silvia alles dafür geben
um endlich Frieden zu finden für ihre
Familie und für sich ja das ist es mir
wert soll den Mörder nicht so leicht
gemacht werden also sie sollen immer das
Gefühl haben wir kleben noch irgendwo
wir wir geben nicht auf ich gebe nicht
auf ich will das nicht drei versprechen
komm um zu beten habe ich erfüllt ich
habe meine Eltern gepflegt ich bin da
bis zum Lebensende für euch und jetzt
ist es noch den Mörder finden einer von
dreien und da hoffe ich dass ich das
schaffe alle die an dem Fall beteiligt
waren die ermittelt und gekämpft haben
setzen auf Hinweise der Bevölkerung auf
eure Hinweise bleibt bis zum Schluss
dran es gibt noch wichtige Informationen
bis zum nächsten mal euer Sky
Dumont am 1 Juli
1989 besucht die junge Krankenschwester
Carmen kleem eine Party im Jugendclub
dem heutigen Volkshaus sömmerd in der
weißenseerstraße
33 gegen Mitternacht macht sie sich mit
einer Freundin auf den Weg nach Hause
ihre Wege trennen sich in der
Bahnhofstraße am Krankenhaus carmen ist
von da an allein unterwegs erst vier
Tage später am 6 juli wird ihre Leiche
im gebüch hinter einer tonnhalle
gefunden der Nachbar Holger s wird als
Hauptverdächtiger ermittelt aber aus
Mangel an Beweisen wieder freigelassen
sollten Sie Hinweise haben die den
Ermittlern in irgendeiner Weise nützlich
sein könnten wenden Sie sich bitte an
die Polizei oder die Staatsanwaltschaft
Erfurt helfen sie syvia ihr letztes
Versprechen einlösen zu
können Tatort Deutschland ist eine
Produktion aus den wakewor Studios
Projektleitung Simone terbrack
Produktion Fabian Scheffler Drehbuch
natthja Goldhammer Redaktion Bild
Karsten keeher und Stefan
Netzeband